Come with me...
and let's build the future...
together.
What do you care about?
When were you happiest?
Make a business out of that feeling.
What do you think
when I say, "Workspace?"
Cubicles...
ugly furniture...
bad fluorescent lighting...
death.
Exactly.
The future of work looks different.
We're selling an experience.
We.
We need a name.
"We."
-"WeLive."
-"WeDream."
"WeWork."
Who wins in a fight?
The smart guy?
Or the crazy guy?
Are you crazy enough?
I may be.
Is Adam for real?
I wouldn't be with him if he wasn't.
The wife, she works there.
She helps him manifest things.
We are on track
to lose 400 million this year.
I built this.
Enough, Adam!
Well, I feel trapped.
You have to make them see.
See what?
You're a supernova.
You're afraid that he outshines you...
Can I get a single of Adam?
...because he does.
Are you a maverick or a muse?
A muse.
Tell me about your goals.
I wanna be in Vanity Fair.
Vanity Fair is not for muses.
Then I wanna change my answer.
I wanted you to meet
the legendary Adam Neumann
-and his wife--
-Chief Branding Officer.
We lease office space.
Then we act like
we're changing the world.
They're turning on you.
You're going to sink the ship.
That's 1.9 billion in losses.
Nothing is more important...
than us.
I have a responsibility to think bigger.
I'm a golden goose laying golden eggs.
You couldn't do this without me.
We're going to war!
We do this together,
we can change everything.